what's going on guys this is rob and i
apologize for the echo here i
am currently recording in a room that's
empty so i will do what i can to fix the
echo but i am moving back to colorado so
by the time you see this
i will hopefully be there but as you may
have heard despite the generally
accepted fact that the moment where
johnny cage does the splits and hits
goro and the balls for breaking his 500
glasses is unlikely to be topped by any
moment that's ever been put on film
they're making another mortal combat
movie so in celebration of that we're
going to cover some of the more popular
characters in the mortal kombat
franchise
starting with one that's become so
synonymous with the series that he was
incorporated into the logo of its
developer
scorpion and so for this video we're
going to start by covering the history
of scorpion within the mortal kombat
mythos and then we'll go over his
fighting style and his unique abilities
within the game
because this is 10 minute expert so
scorpion was one of the seven playable
characters introduced in the original
mortal kombat game in 1992 and he's
appeared in all of the subsequent games
except for 1995's mortal kombat 3 which
did not sit well with a large portion of
the fan base now later that year
midway the game's developer and
publisher released an updated version of
the game called
ultimate mortal kombat 3 which i loved
which did include
scorpion now as for his origin
scorpion's real name is hanzo hasashi
and his father was a member of the shira
ryu clan of ninjas in japan
now this clan was an offshoot of the
chinese clan known as the lin kuei
and were formed when one of the clan
named takeda left the clan to return to
his native japan
from china now takeda began teaching the
martial arts that he learned
and spread it throughout japan
eventually evolving into ninjutsu but
the lin kuei were already angered that
takeda had left the clan an offense that
was punishable by death and the fact
that their secret martial arts had
become widely known
thanks to his teachings infuriated them
even further and so the two clans would
be rivals for generations now one
byproduct of this rivalry was that the
shirai rio adopted the signature
uniforms of the lin kuei
but changed the colors from blue and
black to yellow and black as a way to
insult their rivals even further so at
this point these guys were just being
dicks
toasty but as a child scorpion was
forbidden from joining the shirairu
because his father didn't want him to
become an assassin like he was and so
scorpion
joins anyway which turns out to be a
pretty big mistake as the shirair were
wiped out by a demon
named quan chi now scorpion did not stay
dead however and return
from the nether realm as an undead
specter been on gaining revenge on those
responsible for his death
and his clan's demise now due to some
dark magic meddling by quan chi however
scorpion erroneously believes that the
man responsible for wiping out the shira
ryu was a warrior from the lin kuei
named b han who you probably know better
as sub-zero but following the mortal
kombat tournament held by shang tsung at
the behest of the ruler of outworld
scorpion briefly teams up with sub-zero
to fight shang tsung's army but then
kills him and then vanishes now by the
time the next installment rolled around
it was time for another tournament and
it seemed like sub-zero was back from
the dead we learned however as scorpion
does that this
is not the sub-zero that he'd killed but
his younger brother now the new sub-zero
is committed to completing his older
brother's mission by killing shang tsung
an idea that scorpion had definitely
gotten behind and he also feels a little
guilty for killing this dude's brother
so he vows to be a protector of the new
sub-zero good guy scorpion
kills your brother and then treats you
with respect because he feels bad for it
now in mortal kombat 4 we see the
introduction of quan chi as a playable
character and he deceived scorpion into
believing that sub-zero was responsible
for the eradication of his clan and the
death of his wife and son and this game
had character-specific endings which was
really really awesome and it depended on
who you played as
wrong jerick this is not a brutality
this is a fatality
and this became a little confusing
because they didn't all line up with one
another because at this point the
developers didn't really seem
interested in creating one cohesive
story for the franchise
but if you beat the game of scorpion
you're seen standing over sub-zero
bragging about avenging the death of his
family now sub-zero tells him his
family's killer is still free at which
point quan chi appears and reveals
himself to be the one responsible for
the death of scorpion's family and that
he simply needed the strength of a
spectre to defeat his nemesis sub-zero
so he'd manipulate a scorpion into doing
it for him now quan chi sends scorpion
back to the nether realm the scorpion
grabs quan chi and they're both taken
through the portal sub-zero's ending
basically tells a slightly different
story the scorpion had agreed to fight
on kwon chi's behalf
in exchange for his freedom from the
nether realm but that quan qi
had no intention of honoring the deal
and didn't need to know that sub-zero
had killed him and that both scorpion
and sub-zero had been used as pawns for
shinnok a fallen elder god now as it
turns out
scorpion wasn't as dead as he appeared
and he kills quan chi
telling sub-zero their beef was
basically settled and the sub-zero was
free of scorpion's curse so that's
awesome now in 2002's mortal kombat
deadly alliance we see how scorpion's
ending from mortal kombat 4 was actually
supposed to play out as he's now
committed to finding and killing quan
chief
instead finds himself being met with two
demons named draman
or drama as i like to call him and
moloch who've been hired as bodyguards
for quan chi now these two demons throw
scorpion into a soul nato which is
exactly what it sounds like a tornado
made out of souls and it's amazing which
would have trapped him in a state of
limbo between earth realm and outworld
but as we see in mortal kombat deception
he somehow escaped from the soul nato
and goes on to encounter elder gods who
he agrees to serve to stop the dragon
king onaga who's reemerged from the
grave and is planning to unite all the
six realms now in mortal kombat
armageddon scorpion takes a deal to
serve the elder gods in exchange for the
restoration of his family and the shirai
ryu clan
now the elder gods agree but bring them
back basically is zombies so most guys
are kind of dicks the scorpion is really
pissed by this as he deserves to be and
tries to steal the power of the fire
element blaze to kill the elder gods but
he's unsuccessful and scorpion himself
ends up getting killed by sub-zero and
that's basically it as far as scorpion's
story goes or at least it would be
if the series hadn't basically rebooted
its continuity in the release of the
2011's mortal kombat game now this
tweaked scorpion's story by making him a
servant of quan chi but he's still kept
in the dark
about quan chi's role in the death of
his family and the shirai ryu clan
scorpions once again
bitter rivals with the original sub-zero
bihan because he blames him for the
death of his clan and his family now
scorpion makes a deal with raiden to
spare sub-zero's life in exchange for
resurrecting his clan but after
defeating sub-zero scorpion goes back on
his word and then kills sub-zero after
quan chi shows him a vision of sub-zero
killing his family which prompts bihan's
brother to basically go on a mission of
revenge for his fallen brother now this
new sub-zero defeats scorpion but is
kidnapped by the new cyborg leaders of
the linque
cyrax and sector before he can deliver
the killing blow now eventually both
scorpion and sub-zero are liberated from
quan chi's influence and they put their
differences aside to form an alliance
now after the next several years
scorpion rebuilds this clan but this
time around they're dedicated to the
defense
of earth realm and so when mortal kombat
11 a new villain emerges in the form of
chronica the mother of the elder god of
death and corruption shinnok now
chronica's intent is to merge the past
and present timelines
and as part of that she basically brings
a younger version of scorpion into the
present day but while trying to recruit
allies to the army being built by raiden
to oppose chronica a present-day
scorpion
is killed by devorah who serves chronica
and so with his last breath the older
scorpion
implies his younger self to abandon his
quest for vengeance and fight alongside
the defenders of earth realm
against cronica and his younger self
ultimately agrees so the game ends when
chronic is defeated but once again
there are character specific endings
although not considered completely
incontinuity i'll mention that in
scorpion's ending he kills cronica and
is in possession of an hourglass capable
of rebooting the timeline
he does this in hopes of bringing his
family back but every time he does they
end up getting destroyed and so he
figures out that an ultra powerful race
known as the titans are responsible for
the inescapable death of his family and
resolves to exact revenge upon them so
that's basically scorpion's story as it
plays out in a video game franchise and
so now
we can move on to his abilities as a
combatant of course like
every combatant in mortal kombat he's
skilled in both armed and unarmed combat
with his signature weapon being a spear
attached to a chain
that he launches at his opponents and
then uses it to bring them within
punching distance while shouting get
over here
which i gotta be honest man like when
they did that in like the mortal kombat
movie like i was expecting like this
epic moment right where like scorpion's
just like get over here and it's like
this super dramatic thing and he's like
get over here buddy and i was like dude
this sucks man like it was the least
exciting get over here that i've ever
heard like i was like okay come on like
you know
but regardless my little tangent aside
in addition to his spirit scorpion
routinely employs other
weapons most notably his twin short
swords and the more recent appearances
scorpion's also able to manipulate
hellfire and he frequently does this by
summoning it beneath his opponent
curling fireballs at him
or taking off his mask and then spitting
in his opponents from a skeleton-like
head now finally
scorpion's also a skilled necromancer
and is capable of summoning demons and
other spectral creatures to attack his
opponents and if all of that sounds
really badass well that's the reason
scorpions become not only one of the
most popular mortal kombat characters in
the entire franchise but one of the most
popular characters in video game
history so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thanks
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace